hi Roger here from Google cloud and in
this video we'll have a look at how
contact center AI can help the financial
services industry by transforming your
customer service various external events
like natural disasters can have serious
impacts on financial institutions such
events can create an influx of requests
from customers looking for information
and support but limited human resources
unprecedented network infrastructure
loads and restrictions on travel and
working from offices can hinder
financial services organizations ability
to deliver critical services to their
customers and communities this can put a
huge strain on a number of
infrastructure and core business systems
one area that bears the most strain is
where customers directly interface with
your business things like call centers
and customer support lines can see
unprecedented volume increases and if
you're not set up to handle the scale
your customers could suffer for example
long wait times on hold or an email
query going to long before being
responded to can lead to unhappy
customers and potentially long live
conversations that drive up costs for
call centers the simplest solution is to
increase your service forces to respond
to demand but that's not always as easy
as it sounds the cost of hiring and
training new support workers can have a
significant impact on your operational
efficiency and your profitability the
bottom line is that during times of high
volume customer needs your company will
have to find the balance between
offering exceptional customer service
and personalized intuitive customer care
while increasing operational efficiency
thankfully Google Cloud contact center
AI CCAI is here to help CCAI uses
artificial intelligence to converse
naturally of customers and expertly
assists human agents on more complex
cases CCA is conversational Corp hours
three key features virtual agent gives
customers 24/7 access to media
conversational self-service with
seamless handoffs to human agents for
more complex issues agent assists
empowers human agents with continuous
support during their calls by
identifying intent and providing
real-time step-by-step assistance
insights uses natural language
processing to identify call drivers
sentiment that helps contact center
managers learn about customer
interactions to improve call outcomes
let's see how contact center AI is
helping transform the financial services
industry hi Priya thanks for calling our
bank how can I help
hi I'd like to pay my bill great
can you please verify your address 15
State Street oh and how much is it
virtual agent provides immediate
conversational support with customers
directing the flow you all one hundred
and fifty dollars do you want to pay
with the account ending in 1337 yes
please
done I've sent an email confirmation is
there anything else virtual agent can
take care of basic fulfillment on the
spot yes actually there's a $35 charge I
don't recognize from last week it looks
like it's an overdraft fee oh that's not
fair right I didn't know okay let me
transfer you to a specialist to help
more complex cases are seamlessly handed
off to a human agent high-pressure I'm
Elliot I see you're concerned about the
overdraft fee yeah I didn't know I would
get charged okay I can waive the fee
this time but would you like overdraft
protection so it doesn't happen again
agent assist listens in giving real-time
step-by-step guidance yes please okay
I've set it up is there anything else no
this was great
thanks a lot lastly insights gives you
real-time visibility it's a key call
drivers and sentiment but there are so
many more places CCAI can be leveraged
in financial services for example it can
streamlines a user's ability to manage
their account information like password
resets or it can help facilitate the
user paying their bills activating or
deactivating credit cards or other types
of transactions CCAI can help with
bigger scope tasks like helping
customers generate and understand their
credit scores and view or redeem rewards
for their memberships based upon
transactions
with lots of features like sentiment
analysis multilingual support automatic
topic determination and chat level
analytics CCAI provides a versatile tool
to handle a number of solutions to
improve your customers experience with
your company if you'd like to know more
visit the link in the description below
you can also subscribe to our cloud
YouTube channel for more great contacts
enter AI content
[Music]